not even a year into the administration
and we've already seen crisis after
crisis pile up on president biden but
biden's botched withdrawal from
afghanistan remains one of the worst as
americans to this day are still stuck in
that god-forsaken country living under
the brutal taliban rule and the number
of trapped americans are estimated to be
in the hundreds remember we were told
just about a hundred former u.s envoy to
afghanistan who brokered this deal if
you can call it that zhao may calazad
thinks that might indeed be the case
how many americans remain in afghanistan
today i think
it's very likely that it'll be
in hundreds but
we don't know
whatever happened to no american left
behind here we are months later if the
administration wants to point fingers or
act like we can trust the taliban this
woman in afghanistan says
all you need to know
there's not one single person
one single woman that i've talked to
that does not want to get out of
afghanistan
i mean there's not not even one joining
me now is a guy who's been to
afghanistan as much as any lawmaker in
the country senator lindsey graham
senator
that is the state of afghanistan uh it
turns out the bbc report according to
the world bank the nation's considered
aid dependent
and it might be
uh that might be the worst if not one of
the worst if not the worst humanitarian
disasters right now in the world what do
we do
right
well number one if you're looking for
somebody to blame joe biden needs to
look in the mirror what do we do we try
to save the children from being starved
to death uh without empowering the
taliban so there's a couple things i
want you to know how did we get here joe
biden is the most incompetent president
in my lifetime
he had a plan that did not work he
turned down sound military advice they
don't know if there's 350 americans left
behind or 700 we do know there are
thousands of afghans who fought along
our side that have been left behind but
here's what we also know that
afghanistan is in free fall al qaeda is
flourishing isis is getting stronger and
the taliban told the state department
our state department they would not help
us when it comes to trying to control al
qaeda who is sworn to kill us all if
they could so i consider that action by
the taliban refusing to help us when it
comes to policing al qaeda a declaration
of war is tanamat declaring war on the
united states if you're not willing to
help us deal with our al-qaeda problem
the world's al-qaeda problem then you
really that's a hostile act to me under
the law of war so the afghanistan is the
biggest national security threat uh in
the near term it's the biggest
humanitarian disaster on the planet uh
in in immediate terms and over time it
only gets worse
yeah daryl isis said today they give you
this false choice they'll go up to an
american and say hey you can leave but
you got to leave your family behind
we'll come get them later when you say
no you become somebody who doesn't want
to leave afghanistan that's why there's
300 plus that he helped get out
personally over in california with
democrat help i want to move on to talk
about two things that happened in
virginia stacy abrams showed up and
mcauliffe was there and he basically
said stacey abrams really won the
election in georgia i thought you
weren't dispute weren't supposed to
dispute elections and president obama
showed up because mcauliffe's on a
respirator politically and he said don't
fall for these fa uh these phony
trumped-up culture wars is what's
happening with crt
culture wars
number one it's not a culture war it's
declaring war on the united states
history uh who we are as a people trying
to blame people had nothing to do with
events that occurred in history because
of their race that's offensive to me and
what terry mcauliffe said is that stacy
abrams is really the legitimate governor
of georgia because she was cheated
because the georgia republicans
disenfranchised people from voting and
obama said that republicans are
intentionally trying to keep black
people from voting
now all i can say that's obama bs what
we're trying to do is keep voting
integrity in place i want everybody to
vote but i don't want anybody to cheat
and melon voting is right for fraud so
have you heard anything about this in
their in the mainstream media where
president obama accuses every republican
in these battleground states of being
racist but trying to disenfranchise
black voters because we want to bring
integrity to the ballot
what a double standard and to the people
of virginia you can send a message to
the world not just to the united states
that we've had it with this
woke-ism and double standard yep uh it's
uh right now the race is too close to
call but there was a statistical tie uh
real quick this spending palooza are
they gonna go is it gonna work
yeah they'll get something and it'll be
a shell of about probably half of what
it was before but it's going it's going
to be an inflation bomb it's going to
lead to inflation we don't need all this
additional spending so it's going to be
an inflation bond between inflation and
a likely terrorist attack originating
from afghanistan in the near future
we're in a real real bind senator
lindsey graham thanks so much always
great to see you
thank you hi everyone i'm brian kilmeade
i want you to do me a favor i want you
to click to subscribe to the fox news
youtube page this is the only way that i
know for sure that you're not going to
miss any great commentary any great news
bites any great interviews coming your
way on fox you can get it all here on
youtube so subscribe right now